hello everybody
happy thursday morning and happy almost
resident evil village day ben how you
feeling
uh i'll be honest i'm gonna keep it real
with you i'm very excited to play
residual village
when my copy unlocks and i'm low-key
kind of jealous that
you've been having a chance to kind of
go at it but now you're you're here to
show off some of it this morning for all
of us
i am i am sorry about that i was turning
off my my ac
uh yeah we're playing some resident evil
village thank you all for joining us
we're going to be keeping it uh spoiler
free as
possible i say as possible because um
a game like this is kind of hard to be
completely spoiler free
but um i went ahead and found a
uh save here um
about an hour into the game
um or maybe a little more i skipped
cutscenes so
that timer might not be right but this
is uh
past the intro and this is past both
demo sections so uh i wanted to
because there's kind of like a tight
window where it's like stuff that i i
can show and stuff i can't show
um either because capcom didn't want us
to show it or because
uh to be frank i just don't want to
spoil it for you guys um
and also i didn't want to show you guys
the demo stuff because you've all seen
that like a billion times now you know
yeah it's it's
worth mentioning you've you've finished
this game so you know exactly what is
this big spoiler
exactly not big spoilers um so i picked
this section that like i said is right
after the demo um should be
a a good time so here we are we're in
the castle we got our boy the duke here
um let's just see what i
got i need two new items for you mr
winters
you saw my stuff um by the way if the
chat has any questions
uh then we'll we'll relay them
it's true i'm i'm sitting here i'm
looking at this and i got good news for
you kirby
neither of us are journalists so you're
in good hands
oh okay
is that a concern in the chat oh they're
just like don't play the game like a
game journalist i'm like that's
it's not a thing but it's not a thing
but also no
um hopefully i'll play well i am playing
like
through my obs so uh it seems fine like
there's not much lag but um that could
be a little bit of a concern okay what's
my money at i actually can't see it
because of my
uh that that much money okay cool
um a good amount a good amount i'm gonna
upgrade the
shotgun i'm gonna upgrade that pistol i
can't upgrade the pistol
uh i'll wait then um
rob brings up the concern they feel that
zombies and other creatures
are too bullet spongy do they feel
bullet spongy to you after
after you've played for a bit
yes and no but like in a good way like i
found i found it to be they could be a
little bullet spongy
um especially if you play on the
hardcore
uh but i like that about it because i
think
the balance there feels pretty good
where there feels like there's a good
amount of tension
um plus like as you upgrade weapons
it becomes better so like eventually
like you can like one shot with shotguns
if you like
get that that could get critical um so
yeah so i got a couple of things i can
buy here
uh i got my upgraded case i could buy
recipe stuff to make ammo you can buy
things like first aids and
um shotguns and stuff but they he does
have a limited stock
available and then like as you progress
and you find him in new areas
his stock will like replenish over time
i can also buy
uh weapon upgrades uh also i have here i
have two other weapons i have the
samurai's edge which is
the um the gun
samurai edge yep it came with the deluxe
edition i believe
which was the code we got for the game
um and then i have
also i have this assault rifle that uh i
only have because
i beat the game and i i bought it in the
extras menu
um and and so like there are there are
bonus weapons that you get
um after you beat the game and you and
you replay it again
uh so i'm sort of tempted to try this
but i
also like i don't know if that's like a
a
oh i don't have enough do i have enough
inventory for it though there's no
attach ak
space for this gun oh no it might not be
you got it
tetris this stuff let's see if we can
touch it but i don't know if i can
i might actually actually wait a minute
hold on hold on hold on
oh you've got some some plans you've got
some some things going on oh yeah
um no that might not work
uh uh james garzan wants to know how
long was the game like how long did it
take you to get through
uh it took me about uh my
my hour count said like i think it was
like nine and a half hours
but uh looking at my captured footage it
was more like
ten and a half hours um i'm not sure why
that that was a little different but
yeah about about
like nine to ten hours i would say for
my playthrough
um and that was playing on
standard okay we're making moves we're
making things happen here
i feel i feel like you're you're you're
making it yeah yeah yeah john
did it there's there's that the
beautiful thing with the attached shape
case you
find a way to make it fit also i'm now
realizing i actually have this uh
you can just customizable part i can
throw on my pistol that'll free up even
a little
more room um you can also throw some of
those shotgun shots in there oliver is
saying
to load up your uh you're right you're
right let's do all that
and then
let's shortcut you to here
dang look at this thing so this got 20 i
don't even know what kind of bullets
this thing takes
handgun bullets okay it is handgun ammo
i think
doesn't seem like it's handgun ammo it
might be its own type of ammo
yeah it's it's got the the it's not
unless that's showing what type of
shots it has interesting okay
because there aren't there aren't really
um assault rifles
in this game at least in like the base
experience so
to get them kind of post game is is
interesting
um okay so uh
we're just trying to explore this castle
find rose
um i think i got a lockpick
i do let's go let's go get that uh
uh nick wants to know is there some kind
of end game or
how is the replayability for it so there
is
um once you beat the game you unlock
um access to a
like shop where you can buy um using
your your cp points you can buy
stuff like concept art it's how you
unlock mercenaries
[Music]
you can unlock extra weapons like i said
you can also unlock unlimited ammo
versions of weapons for replayability
[Music]
you'll if you if you bought the deluxe
edition you'll automatically unlock
shadow um village of shadows mode which
is like
uh ethan must die just like this super
brutal hard mode
um and uh but you can also unlock it
naturally
by playing the game i don't know the
exact requirements for it um because
like i said i just kind of already had
it unlocked
but that seems like a super ultra hard
mode that you know
could be could be fun or could be
terrible i don't really know i've got to
mess with it too much
um there also are a bunch of challenges
that you get um that just give you like
cp points
uh that um are like fun for replaying
you can go back and be like oh i'm gonna
replay with
with uh you know i didn't do this
particular challenge where i
uh one was like you checked all the
outhouses you opened every outhouse
store in the game
or like stuff like that uh so there's
definitely like things to go back to and
do that you'll
have missed like i said there's
different weapons you can run through
and play with
um and then there's also mercenaries
mode uh i've got this
actually so replayability pretty solid
uh definitely recommend
playing the game um on
on like hardcore or something uh whether
either for your first playthrough
or just playing it again on a second
time like those those different
difficulties are
quite a bit of fun um i am i don't know
for a fact but i'd be curious if they
have even more difficulty modes kind of
like resident evil 3 had
nightmare mode and that like changed
things up quite a bit
i would love for this game to have a
mode that actually has like
limited saves like uh madhouse did in
seven
but i'm not aware of anything like that
i haven't heard about anything i haven't
seen anything so
something tells me it's not in the game
um
that would be cool yeah
uh not gonna lie literally just sitting
here waiting for lady to pop out
oh it'll happen we'll get there i'll get
there for sure
because we're we're in her house we're
in her home right now yes
there is a section that if we get to
i'm trying to like remember how early
you get to it but um
i'm a little like i can't show it but
it's just like this one part
and i'm like i'm like thinking like if
we get there too early like maybe i'll
just cut away and do it really quick
uh so that i don't get in trouble with
capcom
but i also can keep showing you guys
more the game after that
i see uh
i do like a good capcom specifically
censored
uh lady d part we're just
like no no please don't please don't
show this
okay let's see let's see
sorry i'm like just checking everything
i i'm i'm compulsive
we're all like be like oh i haven't the
room's still red i haven't found
everything yet
yeah uh ghosts asks where where are we
talking at so we're
we're looking at multiple chats right
now uh but i i see you over there
uh see you hanging out
oh there we go
oh we still got the the hidden like
crystal things up inside of stuff oh
yeah
you like resident evil 4 baby they get
you covered
let's see
i never actually like got this room to
there was always like something i was
missing on the wall
or something
watch it's like there's there's like a
diamond hidden in the chandelier that's
impossible to see the glint four
exactly dude there are because the game
looks so good you're just like is that
glenn
is that glenn uh is that a natural glint
or is that an artificial glint exactly
i can't tell
there's so much to break flip oliver
called out the suit of armors being a
thing that are going to definitely come
and attack you
yeah i feel like that's probably going
to happen
i i yeah i will say this game um
if you feel like anything could happen
at any moment
you're you're really on edge the whole
time in a
beautiful way i highly recommend playing
this game with headphones by the way
uh the the sound design is so good
oh you got to give the wine up to the
thing so it lets you in the back the
back way
and then i get the key for the courtyard
excellent so this is this is the the
door that you try to open
up the demo isn't it or is this a
different door oh you were in this store
in the demo the demo
the demo door was uh
uh oh oh yeah the one at the end of the
demo uh which
yeah the the the original maiden demo
i think yeah yeah yeah and then like she
shows up at the end yeah
she's like no you're not going to go
this way oh oh no
there she be all right we're just gonna
oh oh okay or she's gonna just grab me
wow did you you gotta get you gotta get
bitten once
uh you look like you're not having a
good time oh i'm doing bad be honest
hold on there we'll uh we'll solve that
in a sec um
can i this is all on purpose i'm just
showing you guys how the crafting works
of course of course
oh she wasn't there that time nope
okay this was another area that i
scavenged forever and i still had like
one
red thing and i was driving me up the
wall
oh it's daniel moreno talking about how
how much they love the art direction of
the game i completely agree
dude it looks good to see you it looks
so good
also thank you for joining daniel
uh i i was messing with like the photo
mode a little bit
which is okay um it doesn't give you as
much camera control as you want you kind
of are stuck to like wherever
ethan happens to be which is
disappointing um but
it still is like man this game just
looks
so freaking good uh
all right i'm gonna want to head it's
okay ghost i also got bamboozled and
thought the big lady was going to show
up at the door
that's how they keep you on your toes
man yeah
there we go
all right so this is yeah i need a key
for this one
we keep talking about the the sound too
in this game and
oh wait a minute
sorry i stopped the first lady d
sighting of the stream you gotta get
excited for it
uh but the the sound in the game and one
of the the big things i wanted to like
make sure it had
because coming from the midwest where
there's a lot of snow
one of the most eerie sounds that i can
think of in my head
is because snow mute sounds
and having that be in the game because
there's snow everywhere
is neat yes and i'm into that
all the stuff where you're outside in
the village with the like the snow
crunching and the everything is just
making little creaking sounds it's
oh it's really unnerving yeah
okay uh
what have you done to my daughter
[Applause]
uh she was more like what did she do to
you
like you tried to leave her alone uh
she's maybe referring to a
different thing that happens oh i see i
skipped past
sean luke i can't believe this you're a
guest in her home
i may have done a bad what the heck man
you know what i'm gonna keep i'm gonna
break all her things i'm gonna keep
doing it bad
oh yeah there's also like a challenge
for like breaking all the windows in the
uh
the mansion so uh really yeah i should
do that more
when you get that look you can hear that
that wind
yeah spooky ominous
i love how many bullets are just inside
of all of these drawers
that's a normal thing it's a normal
thing to keep in your giant mansion
and gunpowder yeah like you do
it's not so cool my game doesn't get
here until tomorrow and there's nothing
with spoilers
yeah it does kind of suck to have people
have the game and be out there spoiling
stuff yeah i'm
not not into that i i really do believe
this game
is best experienced uh you know for the
first time on your own
um that's i really enjoyed like just
kind of discovering things about it so
uh like i said we're gonna try to keep
it spoiler free here but i wouldn't
trust the rest of the internet
definitely
definitely keep keep away from all that
stuff you don't want to get spoiled on
this game
yeah but i i feel the exact same way
because i also haven't gotten
to play it yet jj and i'm i i trust
i trust john luke to take me on a on a a
pretty good
like here's what the game's got and
we're not gonna
spill big story stuff yeah so i'm i'm
i'm going on the journey with you
yeah while i wait for my game to unlock
it's a bit of a bummer because um there
are other sections in the game
uh that i would show that i think would
be relatively spoiler free
except for the fact that
your objective marker that pops up every
time you pop up the um
the uh the attack [ __ ] case is hella
spoilery
so it's really yeah it's a thing where
it's like what i'm doing right now is
super not spoilery but like at any
moment you can just see a very spoilery
objective and i'm like
yeah i can't can't show that so you'll
open your attached shea case and it'd be
like
go watch jill and leon smooch yeah
exactly
and you're like like watch leonardo in
the game man
that's crazy i can't believe they
finally met in this game my fan fictions
are come to life
right before my eyes um it's it's
another thing i don't think i can talk
about it but ben there is
a uh there's some concept art for a
thing that could have been in this game
that
that i will i will tell you about later
because
okay okay it is
it is like oh man that'd have been so
cool if that was in the game
uh is it jill and leon smooching yeah
it's still only on smudging yeah oh
thank goodness no i'm i'm excited but
but i'm not going to say because i don't
want to i don't want to
spoil anything for people who are like
you know could think that
in the game or you know i don't want to
i don't want to give anything away but
uh yeah look forward to that
uh david from canada says how many hours
into the game this is like you said like
an hour maybe into it an hour hour and a
half
like i said i i this is a save i
specifically made for
the stream so i did skip like a bunch of
cutscenes um
but yeah about about an hour into the
game
hello it's our first boy our first
combat boy
oh he's gone
just like that the wine just like that
that lady deciding it was is quick and
fleeting
but i'll remember it forever uh take a
quick poll in the chat you guys think
this is wine or blood
let me know that's that's the question i
go back and forth i'm like well it can't
be blood that's way too much blood
but i'm also like that's a lot of wine
too though it's the the
the oh [ __ ] oh jeez
oh you got me that got me before it got
me my second playthrough it never
it never not gets me because you get
into a false sense of security you're
like okay whatever
i played this before i know what i'm
doing uh
but this has got to be that like that
the
virginist sanguis flipping
i was going to say my favorite witcher
expansion oh there you go too
uh how many hours for the full game
you're saying like you was
you got through it at like 11 or 12. uh
not nine to ten
for me i understand um there you go but
i i will say uh
gosh i'm doing bad here
oh come on there you go
um i definitely missed a couple things
that
i think if i if i had played it like
super super super thorough it would have
probably been more like 11
to 12. um
so i i would say a pretty good length
for a resident evil game
um yeah like like by the time it was
done it felt like the right amount of
length like the gate i didn't feel like
the game
uh dragged on too long with the
exception of maybe one area where i was
like okay this area's a little
i'm a little over it but uh for the most
part i think the pacing of this game is
quite excellent
they got the literal crystal skull in
here
yeah a lot a lot of crystal themed stuff
all right dead bodies hi on air games
welcome it's good
good to see you
uh ghost wants to know should i buy this
game i haven't given a chance since
they're bad at puzzles
mostly just different from the other
ones uh not just how
how do you feel about puzzles uh there's
not too many in this game and they're
pretty easy
well that's good uh which could be
disappointing for people who are looking
for that but for someone like you who
doesn't like puzzles
might be pretty good there you go
ghost might be a good one for you
um yeah i think it's quite excellent
yeah i feel like like outside of just
the obvious like
re4 look comparison i
i feel like it really is kind of like a
shift towards that kind of
like overall feel oh yeah absolutely
i'm into that i like resident before me
too it feels like this beautiful blend
of of four and seven um
it's like it's like they figured out the
resident evil formula they like know
what to
uh what what to do right after 25 years
of
experimentation they finally nailed it
that's the tagline that's that's where
they're coming from
i will say this feels a lot easier after
because i'm midway through my my
hardcore playthrough
uh and this is like a lot easier
i would say the amount of like shots to
kill don't seem too bad
no no it's a lot more on hardcore for
sure
um and i actually i actually prefer
playing on hardcore um
i'm actually working on a video about
that uh
not to say that uh you shouldn't play on
on
uh standard or you should feel bad for
playing on standard but for me
personally as somebody who like
really likes resident evil when um
it's constantly stressing me out with
like ammo starvation and just
barely having enough to get through a
situation uh
i think the balance on hardcore is like
pretty flawless
so you like your survival horror with an
extra helping of survival in it yes
exactly if you're looking for something
uh
a little more relaxed i would say
standard is perfect because standard
um it can definitely get hairy uh but it
it gives you plenty of of ammo and
bullets in my opinion that
you never feel like too stressed about
it
yeah i don't i don't know if we're uh we
could probably
answer but i don't think we'd want to uh
ghosts they're they wanted to know if
there are any leads on like cliffhangers
to another game and i'm like
i don't know if we'd want to talk about
there being any sort of cliffhangers or
how the ending goes to this
because you know yeah i won't i won't
give any of that away i'd
i'd rather just yeah um we'll keep that
a mystery for you to figure out
once you get your hands on resident evil
village
uh thanks for answering my question
earlier sold me on it heck yeah nick
happy to help yeah of course uh
so it's always a good time when we can
help people figure out stuff about a
game they want to
they want to know what's up with okay so
that section i was talking about is
oh you're gonna have to cut away it is
coming up i might have to cut away a
little soon
um hello i hear a telephone wait hold on
i think i know what the
scene this is yeah we're gonna get a cut
scene here
open up photo mode forget
get get the photo mode going yeah yeah
you can't move
at all in the photo mode though you just
get i couldn't move either she's so
close i'd be so nervous
yo one thing i'll say the brightness
slider
in this game doesn't just blow it out it
actually feels like it's naturally just
adding more light to the scene
like it it it doesn't look too bad in my
opinion
i actually this isn't a bad photo mode
i'm kind of sad that you can't move
around too much it's just the moving
around like
like obviously i'm in a cutscene so i
can't move at all but at least you can
move like the camera but you can't you
can't like move up or down you can't get
aerial shots
it's just like wherever ethan was
standing is where you're locked and
that's that's kind of a bummer but
it is kind of neat that you can do it in
cut scenes because a lot of games won't
even let you do that that's true
um so there you go i like i like that
that's nice yeah
you got that cool little capcom thing
down there save that up
oh look at that zoom in enhanced i wish
i could
uh rich richmond knows
so we'll watch this cut scene here
mother miranda i regret to inform you
it's a bummer i can't show this next
part because it is a good part um
fool heisenberg maybe i'll just play it
and and all
um because he is in my castle and is
already proven too much for my daughters
to handle
you guys can just hear me okay that's
fair
i'm into it no mother miranda
yes of course i understand the
importance of the ceremony
i won't let you down
i'll do the thing yeah ah she's so
strong
ceremony that man will
pay for what he's done it's only 9 30 in
the morning i wasn't prepared for this
we're already throwing around flipping
vanities and stuff
yeah i'd definitely go into that room
after i saw all that happen that's the
logical conclusion of that
look look how yeah look at that i got
dressness
that's the [ __ ] that she needs a
mannequin that big to hold the dress
it's a lot yeah but then all the doors
are just
like way too small for her and i'm like
oh man girl like
shouldn't be able to like readjust that
[ __ ]
all right some some stuff
don't don't want to sleep some cool lore
rose where are you wait why is that baby
bed big enough for ethan to lay in
ethan is the baby that's the plot oh i
can't believe this
she just comes back through the door
ethan get back in the crib i swear to
god
open that door oh [ __ ]
all this for a child who isn't even here
what the hell do you ungrateful
selfish wretch you come into my house
double down it's only 9 30. on my
daughters and now you even try to steal
my raw party
yo she shoved you through the house
and i will break you
lady please go ahead do your worst
uh how are people playing someone
telling you please um xbox one this
we're playing because this is a press
copy
uh we've had access to for doing reviews
and coverage which you can catch
all on our youtube channel and stuff if
you want to get a leg up
maybe some some tips yep check out the
review see what we thought of it
all that stuff yeah
okay so
i need to uh
[Music]
i need to cut away in a sec
okay something's gonna happen i'm not
i'm not allowed to show
uh
drago that's a good point uh if lady d
wanted to she could have literally
killed you right there
it's true i feel like like she's she's
got the power
it's the muscles she's got really pointy
fingers
uh just a lot of stuff but yeah so
bear with us for a second well while
john look gets past uh
a really cool super secret point that we
don't want to have spoiled for you but
we'll be back
i can't see it at all this is not going
to work i can't
okay i believe in you all right i have
to
i'm like oh this is not the demo this is
the full game
but uh we're getting past the cool point
and everything will be will be great yep
that thing happened
okay cool cool i love it when the thing
happens
believe me this is super cool it's
really neat
it's just off the off the chain just it
is actually a cool moment that i
legitimately would not want to spoil uh
so i totally understand
oh god okay uh run run run
this is really hard
i don't know what i'm doing
i like that you're like you're having to
look off in the distance to like
yeah look on the screen i didn't play in
this very well oh god
uh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh uh
is this the right way
yes that's what i need
zayn sorry sorry about that drago and
mobot's
going off the chain but yeah
i didn't even think about that the uh
the
the setting is really neat it's like a
van helsing transylvania vampire lichens
just doing all sorts of cool stuff
okay okay i'm pivoting
i think i'm almost there this is really
hard to play
are you like literally trying to like
look across your room and play unlike
your tv
yes that is exactly what i'm doing
that's what i figured
oh open that door please yes it is there
we go
okay rubble say i just gotta wait people
can play the game and don't show us so
this is for your benefit this is a
really cool moment that we don't want to
have spoiled for you it's a cool moment
i don't want to spoil away so this is
this is for your benefit you don't want
to see this
but you give us like the five minutes to
get past it it'll it'll be worth it i'm
actually
it's actually just about done i'm just
waiting for this uh yeah
end like this this is like the
this is the the cool like non-spoilery
stuff
that we're trying to make sure we
deliver to you guys you can still see
the game
and still keep it exciting for later on
okay
and we're back just like that hey we're
back in the courtyard
uh something happened in between
and there's boys johnny dark souls is
here with the sword ready to play but he
came to the wrong
party ethan still got his
his gun he keeps that thing on him you
know i should try out this uh this
assault rifle i got
i've oh wow yeah
that just status shoots people
i like it
for those of you just joining no you did
this i only have this assault rifle
uh because of a new game plus sort of
like i unlocked it after i beat the game
but it's it's that little bit of like
this is what you you can get
this is the powerful stuff you get your
hands on
i do like that you can shoot the sword
out of his hands yeah yeah you could do
some disarming tactics on people that's
pretty good
uh okay we are
oh hello is just use from the sky
you all good you all done
i don't know i i like that like you
don't just always go for head shots like
shooting things out of people's hands is
a neat thing
another pro tactic is sometimes it's
actually better
to uh guard because
this kick move and sometimes that will
also disarm them
so i love doing melee stuff in games and
a big thing that i miss from like
re4 into 5 and into 6 is being able to
do melee attacks
off of like limb shots oh that's like i
love six because six is all about that
yeah six has got flipping kung fu moves
out the ass
and i love that like the fact that i can
play as sherry and like hurricanrana a
zombie like that's
red as hell like why would i not do that
um so i'm glad that there's more melee
stuff in this game
all right here we go got me a key
also just really likes to think there's
some cool stuff from six i like
jake and sherry's story they hold hands
at the end of it i like sweet i like
jake and cherry's story too actually
that's the one
i i do not like resident evil 6 but jake
and
sherry's story is just the right amount
of schlocky nonsense that i'm actually
i actually quite enjoy it yeah and we'll
never see jake again no that's the worst
thing we'll
never see that character again resident
evil loves to introduce concepts and
and plot lines and then just drop them
my uh my always my favorite go-to joke
is rebecca chambers is the character
that resonates with forgot but it's
actually jake
it really is um i love by the way i love
this little section of the castle
because it super reminds me of the
spencer mansion
i was going to say you got a safe room
down at the bottom of the stairwell i
bet
just hanging out
like look at this look at this
look at this game
i got a question about you missing
fingers is your character missing
fingers
uh ethan is maybe missing some fingers
oh no as for why you'll have to play the
game to find out
i'm surprised he didn't just pour some
goop on him and reattach him again
uh i think i think those fingers were in
a night he was unable to retrieve them
oh it's i see
i think i might i think i might know
where this had gone
oh that's cool we can do that little
puzzle later that'll be a fun one um
wish you could take your swords inside
yeah some some like more melee combat
put more melee combat in resident evil's
bring it bring it back
i still remember like reading the
previews of the original resident evil
remake
a long long time ago for the gamecube
and they're like it was like a stem off
from like the defensive weapons where
they had like
the letter openers and the the tasers
but they were actually going to put like
hand-to-hand combat in at one point
oh wow yeah and i remember seeing like a
screenshot in like a nintendo power
magazine or like a game pro where they
had like
jill literally doing like a like a like
a kick
as a person who loved metal gear solid
this is the stuff that i'm in for and
i'm really sad that didn't actually come
through but put more melee in resident
evil agreed
okay a little puzzle here a little piano
puzzle
why you get to play a piano
[Music]
uh how long before we get this and
someone plays megalovania on it
and i'll pose it to youtube because you
know what's going to happen
[Music]
oh come on
ethan's really good at playing the piano
with missing fingers
multi-talented guy a heck of a
heck of a protagonist now he's got he's
got characteristics
it's got features um
this isn't really a spoiler but my my
favorite uh line of dialogue in this
game
is there's a throwaway line of dialogue
where uh to explain how ethan
is like more capable in this game where
he just mentions like yeah i got this
military training
oh okay in between like games and i'm
like okay
the the like frank west equivalent of
i've covered wars
yeah it's just this throwaway line that
they put in just to explain like here's
why ethan's
a more capable guy with with guns now
they're like oh okay sure
i'll buy it yeah we'll buy it why not uh
i mean after my experience in resident
evil 7
i too probably would have picked up some
military training
but where you get military training i
couldn't tell you
so uh
there the next part is a boss battle
um with one of the daughters i would
like to
pause it to the chat if they would like
to see that or if they would prefer i
don't show that in which case i can kind
of head back
uh right now i'll head back and i'll
i'll do this little puzzle for fun
um but then uh if if that's where
oh hello mom what are you doing here
all right we might be in trouble oh
actually this is kind of a dead end um
it's fine she'll never she'll never find
you in here never ever
dude you're in a bad place yeah i'm in a
real bad spot
oh
uh but if the chap would prefer i don't
show that then we can we can go ahead
and uh
end it here after the puzzle and we'll
uh switch over to mercenaries mode
i do want to see some mercenaries mode
i'm very excited for that
also i'm just in a real bad spot right
now
hello
oh she's gone she's gone she shouldn't
want to chase you into there
oh she's probably roaming around oh you
get military planning
training playing cod so he just he went
to europe and he just played cod for
months yeah
it's you're sure to find
something new she's not going to come in
here
this is this is sacred grass this is the
save room we all know that
she respects the rules so i can take
that uh that flower star ball
and i can do this little little puzzle
i like i like this this is good
must be busy
yes very busy playing puzzles
uh yeah ben let me know if the chat uh
what the chat things about
showing off that that stuff i was gonna
say i don't see anyone
saying anything either way but if you
guys do want to see that boss fighter
not see that boss fight
let us know oh i'll probably just take
whatever the first person says or most
people say
yeah at this point but uh
i'm kind of down to see it myself okay
we can show it i don't want to speak for
everyone in the chat though i'm
i'm i'm different sometimes yes yes
yes yes please i've gotten some check
these things
uh vagrant says yes show it okay
it is a minor boss fight i'll say it's
not in in the grand scheme of boss
fights in this game
it's like i will i will i will not show
like the big boss fights at all uh
those are the big boss fights those to
me are absolutely
uh worth worth uh preserving
uh zak says show it israel says yes boss
okay uh i want to watch so bad but i
don't want spoilers that's understand
kill we're trying to keep it as as safe
as we can
uh chaos does show it uh richmond says
skip it
more people are saying show it okay for
for what it's worth for people who
aren't sure like jonathan it is uh
it is not like a main boss it's not a
mate it's not a main boss
uh but i would say if you're not
interested in being spoiled on it
um maybe maybe cut away from the stream
and if if uh
you want come back in like five minutes
and uh
and then we'll do mercenaries mode which
is no spoilers anywhere except for guns
probably right yeah yeah no real
spoilers
maybe locations not really uh it'll be
the
um the village and then the castle
show so it'll be stuff you guys are
familiar with you could do mercenaries
in the castle
i haven't played that one yet i actually
like unlocked it and i didn't uh i
haven't touched it yet
all right so we're doing the boss then
the mini boss i'm gonna start calling a
mini boss
yeah i would call it a mini boss it's
not it's not a full-on boss but
uh so that'll this would be good i'm
excited yeah so like i said
if you don't want to see this uh maybe
just cut away for the stream for a
couple minutes
um and then come back and we'll we'll
move on spoiler free
uh where am i
oh do i not even have the oh we
built this up we don't even have the key
oh you know what
i think i got i didn't even grab the key
from that uh
from the puzzle yeah it was for the
piano i don't think i actually grabbed
it
hey you know where you're going i was
too busy thinking about the boss and not
wanting to show it
and i totally didn't grab the key far in
the game
is this is like an hour and a half hour
maybe a little bit
mom she's back
dude she's gonna go i'm just gonna
murder you
apologize with your life
no boy i am a okay with this
this is this is it
ah
you just apologize you're running away
full speed i'm sorry
okay just gotta get that door unlocked
she's got to kind of router around here
yeah yeah yeah
oh boy i quite i quite like her
um as a i don't know what you call them
like a stalker stalker
type enemy um yeah kind of mr x and jack
baker
okay okay we're good we're good we're
good
and now we fight the boss so you finally
came to see in a library
you really want to kill me
she says as you've shot three shotgun
shots at her
point blank
why are you oh yeah joe i can't imagine
having to keep this place clean
you'd have to have so many people
why why would you do this
well apparently they like hire maidens
from the village and then they're like
you keep the place clean
and then eventually we just eat you oh
so they've got a cannon
explanation already for why the place is
so clean yeah
i love it it's all the maidens man
damn come on
a dream this is a dream i
don't want it
oh no sick of bugs
yeah i'm sick of bugs too lady was
really bugging me
huh all right there you go
that was that was pretty good yeah
scavenge for some ammo
just gotta clean clean up a bit here
find all the stuff there is to see
yeah it's still red i still got more
stuff to find uh
[Music]
yeah that's gonna be the end of me i'm
literally gonna search everywhere until
it changes color and i guess i'm ready
for that
okay i'll keep moving and i want to hold
up the stream
with my neurotic tendency to just
check everything dude that's it's a real
thing it's
you gotta you gotta check all of it
you've gotta find everything there is to
find
okay more dust for the maidens to clean
up
this brings us back into the hall
great mom's not here again she's she's
off doing whatever she does
and then we're gonna get a little puzzle
here
oh
guess i will spoil this puzzle a little
bit if people are concerned about that
um i gotta shoot all these bells
let's see that one there
the bells
that one there that one on the
yo these are like actually hidden yeah
that's why i said i was gonna
spoil it that's neat okay but yeah
little hidden bells
any more questions in the chat people
curious about
daniel marina wants to know what do you
think mom's doing while you loot her
place
but being very upset breaking breaking
yelling through the hallways the whole
time
i can't believe he's running around just
doing whatever he wants
little treasure map oh i could go get
that i'll get a little extra bonus right
here
hey bruno's dad how's it going it's good
to see you
try hard it's good to see you as well uh
how's the game is it worth buying on day
one uh i haven't played it but you've
you've beaten it and you
are enjoying it i think it's quite
fantastic i feel like
i feel like you'd recommend it oh shoot
now we're gonna have to make a hard
choice a sniper rifle uh
we're we're gonna have to get rid of the
assault rifle which i'm it's fine i'm
not this is not a save i'm uh
you know sticking with yeah
um that's fair
when's the preload on steam that's i
want to know richmond and if you figure
it out please tell me so i can hit that
button and start it up
can i not okay hold on i might have to
like
do it this way oh can i not just like
you can't just ditch the can't just
ditch the gun
that can't be right yeah oh yeah i just
can't get rid of
oh no oh that's no good
that seems like like a bit of an
oversight to me yeah well i mean to be
fair
uh you should have plenty of space at
this point it's just because i have this
thing
um i kind of screwed myself a little bit
uh hold on uh the snip rifle is a is
another two by
like whatever right i think so
like maybe i can try try putting it over
there yeah
maybe i can make that work unless it's
just a little bit longer
oh it might be
wait no no you can't you can't
it's a little too long you can't you
can't put it sideways no it's like one
bar too long
oh uh dang
i'm i am gonna make this work somehow
we put the put the assault rifle up
there and then
wait wait wait
no i know and then i do that
and then this is the most
difficult part of the game and you've
nailed it we did it
look at that boom
eighth stage wants to know if do you
think eight is better than seven
i like it better than seven for you
personally personally i like it better
than seven uh i also
love seven um and to be fair it's not
like
it like overshadows seven
um because like to me like a seventh
aesthetic is so different and unique
and i really love that about it uh so
like
i still love seven and i actually kind
of want to replay it now because um
i think that game's flavor uh that
louisiana texas chainsaw vibes are just
so
good um but in terms of gameplay
i think this game is better
i'm into it okay
uh samuel talks about the the survival
aspect and how what you think of it
you're
you're saying earlier in the stream how
you you cranked up the difficulty to
increase the survival factor because
it's kind of
it's not not up to your your your
preference yeah on lower difficulties
i played it on standard uh which you
can't change midway through so you have
to pick a difficulty and stick with it
uh i played on standard and thought it
was good but i was like
it's just a little little too easy for
me particularly for what i'm looking for
um and then i cranked it up to
hardcore and i've been playing that and
i find it much more satisfying
um as far as just like limited ammo and
the stress of uh making every shot count
having to make like tough decisions uh
oh my god
when it comes to you know of maybe
you can't shoot every enemy you have
sometimes you have to just like run past
them to save ammo
uh that was decisions i never
found myself having to make when playing
on uh
standard but in hardcore i find myself
thinking about that stuff a lot more
um so if that's the kind of experience
you're looking for out of resident evil
i would actually recommend trying
hardcore
i think that's a good recommendation uh
spinowin says thanks for streaming heck
yeah anytime
love love to to show the stuff off or
help answer questions whenever we can
oh god uh that's not the healthy
these guys i'm playing like garbage what
is going on here
oh you're you're answering questions and
stuff man you got you got so much going
on
oh come on there you go stay down uh
joni wants to know how's the gun play
compared to seven
same or any improvements found it was
kind of not
great in seven but to remake it was done
really well
yeah no i i agree like two remake was
like so good and like seven was like
okay um i think this is better
than seven i
would like to go back in two and see how
i feel about it compared to two because
i still think two is just like
peak like gun feel um
you know what ruined two for me i don't
know if i want to tell you because it'll
ruin it probably but
okay uh there are no head shots in
resident evil 2 unless you get critical
hits
so like shooting a zombie in the head is
no different than shooting it in the
foot
uh it does the same amount of damage no
matter where you get shot at
uh i actually did know that um and i
don't mind that in that game but i it is
weird um this game definitely like you
go for
the head um so if you're interested in
that
then yes this game this game's got you
covered um
i will recommend if you are playing
especially if you're playing on
controller
go to the options settings and uh turn
off uh movement
camera acceleration and aim camera
acceleration by default it's on like mid
and when you turn it on it's kind of
hard to show without like actually
playing it
but it has this weird like
slipperiness to it like because like the
the it's accelerating it feels like uh
like you're you're sliding on ice but
with a camera
and it doesn't feel good and i don't
know why they have that set to default
but i don't think it feels very good if
you go ahead and
turn that off way better in my opinion
so a hot tip if you're starting the game
up and you feel
like the movement isn't quite right try
turning that off and see if that
improves your experience uh
oh this is perfect uh i can't pronounce
your name uh because i'm bad with my
my brain but uh they're asking
can we get a separate video for
different difficulties like hardcore
uh
well i'm actually making a video about
hardcore
there you go works making up uh
hopefully it'll be up uh end of the day
today
um if all goes well uh and it'll be
basically like talking about my
experience playing hardcore and why i
think it's the
the better the better difficulty to play
with if that's what you're looking for
so look forward to that so it's a
perfect
a perfect synergy you love to see it the
people
are asking for the video and the video
is already in production
oh are they dead the lighting department
are the real heroes of this game
it's true uh
the lighting the atmosphere everything
going on here oh yeah
very very good top notch
uh what difficulty level are you
currently on jojo kitty wants to know
i'm currently on standard
and that's i just picked it because um
you know streams and whatnot
uh didn't want to make it too hard on
myself
um also i had to like read this is like
a new save i had to make specifically
for this stream
and i was like i'll just pick standard
because i can kind of skip through the
early stuff pretty quickly
hello oh that's the first time i've seen
that happen
i like that it corrected itself at least
but you know
don't like these guys not a fan of
flying flying boys
yeah yeah
resident evil flying enemies aren't what
i
pictured together a lot but they sure do
love to do them
it's true none of them five
five loves it's flying boys
[Music]
time tonight will this be playable i
hope it
nine pst like usual right yeah
because i'm gonna be honest i want to
play this game
right now
okay
grab this last thing here are you about
to take a zipline
you know it ah i have no inventory space
that's okay we're actually about to
can you slam the bullets into the gun
from that spot though
uh oh like like like straight from
the ground no you cannot
yeah you can't do that at least here
maybe
like
no no you cannot dang can't do it
rip uh that's okay though we're about to
actually switch over to mercenaries
right here um because i think this has
been a pretty good
portion of the game to show off yeah
yeah yeah
uh brick wants to know what is the most
memorable moment from resident evil like
as a franchise for you personally
oh that's a good question over over the
whole thing i
if you need time to think i think i know
mine my
[Music]
personal favorite moment in resident
evil
is the uh lisa trevor stuff
in the remake of uh resident evil 1 on
the gamecube
that's lisa trevor's the the that
gamecube version of resident evil
is maybe one of my favorite games of all
time i think that game is
a 10 out of 10 masterpiece
flawless yeah flawless game uh
zero lies detected in all that the
that's
they didn't need to add that stuff in
there and they did and it made it so
much better it made it so much better
that's that's definitely up there but i
think for me it's uh
the the moment in resident evil 3 the
original
uh like after you finally get into the
police station and you head down
to like one of the save rooms and
nemesis jumps through a window
and that's a really good moment yeah
like my my dumb kid brain was like
cool for two games these zombies haven't
been able to like chase me through rooms
and then to have like a boss with a
rocket launcher jump through a window at
me
my mind was blown and i couldn't process
anything after that
and i was too scared there's also that
moment in resident evil 2
when you're i think like outside you're
in like behind the police station and
you open up this one door
and the door animation happens but
instead of going through the door all
these zombies just come
pouring out of the door and you're like
that's not supposed to happen
that this never happens before i can't
believe this
uh resident evil is good resident evil's
real good man
gathers so many moments like that i mean
the the the dog showing up in in four
oh god again
uh jojo kitty says any any lady d
sightings yet
uh a couple but here she is right here
for you
as was almost on cue
a fresh what
little arms where's she making fun of me
for
i have big strong arms lady d please
expanded my services please come take a
look
you got it dude you can show me ways to
pass the time
all right yeah we're gonna buy that [ __ ]
casey i don't know why i'm doing
that we're about to literally stop to
save but
even more it's you know it's there it's
a cool thing to do if you want it
sell all our treasures
computer everyone has alarms it's true
should you be throwing things across
rooms
uh okay why don't we go ahead and no
let's go get ourselves killed by her and
then we're gonna
switch over to mercenaries hello
mom she's back
shall i drink nemesis
all time favorite chasing person but
lady dee's putting up numbers
oh god all right you are dead darn right
we'll do it again oh yeah i got a couple
challenges
uh is this livestream gonna be deleted
later no this will be up nope this will
be up we archive this stuff
um okay so now we're gonna go uh into
bonuses check out mercenaries
oh
oh it's like you didn't even leave
you're just hanging out in the same spot
right back here
naturally okay so
so this is the the new mercenaries mode
setup mm-hmm
we'll check it out we're gonna see
what's up i'm gonna get the shotgun
so they give you like money off the bat
right at the beginning to kind of just
always spend
on things yes they give you a little bit
of money more
dexterous than one might think so you
can get uh like you can pick a
extra weapon if you want um or you can
save it so that you can maybe get like
some of the better weapons
uh
all right let's go i'm not thinking the
same with
daniel the the lighting at that part
where she pulled out her finger
finger swords it's a look
yeah i get the raid mode comparison now
especially because of the floating
damage numbers
and the the life bars
oh yo but the jams are in full effect
and that's what matters the most
the jams are in full effect
okay so we got the timing things too
that's good
oh there's a drop that's happening yep
get a good drop
all right let's see uh
how hard are the nails i saw sparks
they've gotta be they've gotta be real
hard
i should pick a lock from across the
hallway uh
that's the content i'm here for
uh yeah that minecart stuff is real fun
too uh on four
thinking back in uh well there's a
minecart
part in six too
now there is four how many mine cart
rides are there
in resident evil that's the question
it wasn't one in five surprisingly six
six was the one that stuck out in my
mind right away because i'm like oh yeah
you and your friends gotta like duck and
dodge a whole bunch of stuff
and open uh deborah's like
climbing around with her spider arms oh
god debra
right it's a heck of a boss fight that
one
he tried to make her too sexy and it was
weird
yeah there's yeah
[Laughter]
there's a lot going on there
want a physical arcade version so i
shoot a light gun that would be sick as
hell
uh i agree i i really want a vr
uh version of this game
i wonder if they're gonna do mercenaries
in re for
vr too oh they've got mercenaries and
they got it mercenaries in four was a
really good time yeah
come on
oh geez that's a big case
do you like a good use of the landmine
that guy is uh he's got like
like crab claws what's going on there
oh yeah he's uh he's a no good he's a
nasty
it seems like it
i do appreciate enemies go down a little
bit faster in mercenaries to keep the
pacing up
yeah the balance is a little
a little a little better for it
i wonder how much that too is also kind
of uh
because you can see where their health
is at too
maybe but like those those claw dudes uh
they take way more bullets than that to
go down in in the main game
gotcha is this early access or demo this
is the full version of the game
uh we have access to because we needed
it for
doing reviews this press copy
more what the lakenford would be like in
vr we'll all find out
uh eventually
oh yeah that seems really disorienting
yeah
yeah how do we how do the quick time
events work have they talked about that
i have no idea you probably have to move
your hands to do something
uh i'm still like
i'm still thinking about the small
little things that happened in for like
i'm gonna have to tell ashley to get in
a dumpster a whole bunch of times
but for real
alrighty keep
moving as you wish
thinking of playing this uneasy good
idea i'd say if
if you feel like you don't want to like
worry too much about making your way
through it that's totally a viable
option
there's nothing bad about it yeah
totally uh it all comes down to how much
of a challenge you want
and some people don't some people just
want to like experience the game and
have a good time yeah if you're more
interested in the atmosphere
and and you know the vibes of it and
are as can you don't really want to feel
stressed out about the combat and stuff
then yeah like totally play the game on
uh
on easy i think it's called casual in
this game
you're saying that moving the difficulty
up makes it feel like you're
like it limits supplies more and stuff
and makes it feel more
there's more of an emphasis on the
survival aspects and stuff you're saying
yes yes so i would say standard
is is a pretty good uh
a pretty good difficulty where it feels
like you
[Music]
can definitely get in stressful
situations but it always feels like you
have
uh enough resources to feel relatively
comfortable
and as somebody who's like played a lot
of resident evils and and sort of like
is more interested in in a little more
of a stressful experience i found it to
be a little too easy
um so hardcore i found to be that sweet
spot for what i'm looking for
um but but if you're if you're not
interested in that experience or
or want that extra kind of wiggle room
standard's fine
and then like i said if you really just
want to like just not stress it at all
casual is also totally valid yeah
yeah i don't know about that ryan saying
that people who play
games on easy a new hobby that's that's
a bad take i agree
we're not about we're not about that
kind of take here people
people should play games however they
feel like they need to play them and
that's good enough uh
yeah uh that's the thing i want to know
about too though uh what battlebond is
asking is
uh does mercenaries offer any other
characters besides ethan because
mercenaries is a game about
you know mercenaries multiple people
not that i'm aware of um
yeah not that i'm aware of god this
isn't
multiplayer either right no and i
granted i haven't played through all of
mercenaries i've unlocked everything so
i'm not gonna say that there couldn't be
something there but i
to my knowledge i know nothing
gotcha
uh are there red barrels in this game
there are there's one right there
perfect nailed it just on time just like
that
uh this is the full game uh tashi
it's we we got got that full review copy
so we could let you guys get a little
bit of a preview before the game comes
out
try to keep it uh spoiler free have a
good time
slow motion uh oh there we go that
sounds good
uh is there an fov slider on the console
version of the game
oh you know that's a good question
actually i never checked because i know
they
they try to keep it kind of narrow to
like make it feel a little bit
claustrophobic
uh i do not see anything so i don't
think so
dang no sorry does not appear to be the
[Music]
case
i will say in in kind of relation to fov
if you if you feel a little motion sick
playing this game go
turn um like camera bobble off uh i
actually have it off right now
um because my uh partner was feeling a
little ill when we were playing
um but yeah that that is something that
if if
you feel a little motion sick playing it
try turning that off um that might help
yeah uh
dragonfly brings up the the review
saying that there are spoilers in there
i really don't think there were that
many spoilers in that i don't think
there were anything they really are i
mean i
if if you want to go in the game like in
the review
uh phil basically just gives you the
basic intro setup of the game
outside of that he does not spoil
anything that happens at all in fact
i very i'm going to cut the review i
very intentionally
do not show uh any
major sections of the game outside of
the castle and a couple of the village
sections i try and keep the
uh a lot of the areas of the game a
mystery and surprise
um if you're somebody who's like i
literally don't want to know
a single uh thing about the story then
yes he technically does talk about the
story a little bit but uh
i saw some people being like oh he
spoiled the entire story and uh someone
who played the game i can tell you that
is
completely false he absolutely
does not there are so many things that
happen this story
that uh we did not touch on at all
so yeah i i actually got a heads up
about a couple of uh
reviews that had way way more in them
yeah and and i avoided them but i i feel
like ours is pretty safe
i i feel like it's pretty safe you know
um
uh uh igns for example i jin i don't
think spoils the story or anything
um but they do show a couple of
uh late game uh locations and enemy
types
that uh we intentionally didn't show
just because i wanted to preserve that
um so yeah i mean you know everyone kind
of makes their own decision on what they
consider to be a spoiler
and not so uh i'll leave that up to you
but
yep i don't think we spoiled that story
if that's what you're concerned about
if you if you watch that and felt like
you were spoiled on the whole thing
then don't worry there's plenty of that
that story left
that hasn't been touched for you
uh so okay cool take take your word for
it so
yeah we we do try our best to like
make sure that we don't spoil that stuff
because we
care about playing the games as much as
you guys and the last thing we want to
do is ruin
an experience that you're excited for
totally like that but at the same time i
also try and keep that in mind like if
you know if enough people feel like we
were spoiling something i definitely
want to like at least
you know take a look at that and kind of
evaluate and be like okay did we maybe
show too much
in this case i really don't think we did
but uh you know
that is feedback i always try and take
into consideration
like usually like people might be like
oh that's the type of question you don't
want to like try to
talk about or something if someone
brings it up but like i want
i feel like it's a good thing to kind of
be like hey look this is where we're at
and we try to do it we try to
make it work as as best we can and yeah
it's a thing we're cognizant about and
to be able to tell you guys directly hey
we do think about this stuff yeah it's
it's a thing that's definitely on our
minds whenever we we cut reviews or put
videos together
it's important it is
uh cr7
asks uh do you ever play resident evil
outbreak
um i actually never i never played
outbreak
i did a little bit a long time ago
never multiplayer though
but can you even still play the
multiplayer
i was about to say you actually can and
i've been watching people play it
uh in the lord's year 2021 co-op
and it still looks like it holds up and
that might be an interesting thing to
look into
what uh what platform are they playing
it on
you know playstation 2 okay
definitely a legitimate playstation 2
hardware that is not
not a an emulator at all understood i
got it
anything my friend but uh it's it's
it looks neat and it's neat that people
can still play it and there are
there are actually people hosting
a few rooms in it like they're there's
like a small community of people who are
playing it right now that's awesome
i would uh i would actually really love
to play that sometime that would be a oh
that'd be a fun game to get together
with like you and
maybe people and do do like a run
through
because i always thought that idea was
so cool yeah to like
run around and like i didn't i didn't
realize a lot of stuff about it like
where
you start off like say in the police
station chapter and
depending on what character you are you
start in a different part of the police
station and you have to like
sort of stumble into each other
and just all the different characters
having different abilities
it's neat it's an interesting concept
and i kind of wish they'd go back to it
and relook at it now me too
um resident evil over the series has
tried so many different
like multiplayer ideas and i think we're
pretty much all in agreement that
uh they they peak their mercenaries
um but yeah like th that also
seems just like even if that game wasn't
perfect um
it seems like that idea was very strong
and had a lot of potential and i'm
yeah pretty surprised they've never gone
back to trying to do that
well that's a good call out uh lalit i
i hope i said your name right uh saying
that there are people who are
not only just like posting walkthroughs
of the game but they're putting spoilers
in their thumbnails for their videos
i hate that i hate when people put like
a sport like they put like the final
boss of a game
in the thumbnail so we're hating this is
the thing that people experience a lot
because we're we're yakuza fans and
there are people who will import the
game
oh yeah yeah and play it in japanese a
year before it comes out here
and they'll be like ah this wacky boss
fight with this person
a year before we're anywhere close to
getting it yeah just
on the thumbnail in the title and i'm
like i love that you're giving content
for this game series that i love so much
but please oh my god don't spoil these
forms and what's worse is like
because of um uh
because of my job you know like we'll
we'll be like you know
searching youtube or google for uh
videos relating to a game and so you get
that in your recommended feed so
suddenly it's like oh you really like
resident evil here's you watch the
trailer so here's
uh all of these videos that spoil
everything and you're like
thanks youtube recommendations really
appreciate that
um i actually had the other day i mean
thankfully i already beat the game at
that point but i was like
looking up some uh google images for
some thumbnail stuff and i found
um uh straight up images in the google
search result for that like dev kit
version of the game that got
leaked that just showed like the final
boss and like some of the final cutscene
stuff
in like screenshots and i was like wow
that would suck
if i was a random person who just saw
that and hadn't played the game
uh so that stuff is definitely out there
so be cognizant
of that and then you know the internet
safe if you're trying to avoid that
stuff because
oh not a few yeah i just
i get people wanting to rush to like
post that stuff as soon as
they want to be the first but it's it's
uh i don't know
it feels it feels very disrespectful
it's it's a real
weighted thing like do you want to be
the first one there do you want to be
the first one people ignore
like i don't know yeah
yeah it's it's it's uh the the the way
youtube is designed sort of like
encourages that kind of stuff
unfortunately
yeah darkseid chronicles is uh an unreal
shooter it's reno
i played dark side chronicles and the
other
umbrella chronicles yes uh
on the on the playstation though um yeah
playstation 3.
they were interesting
i have those but i've never played them
uh
i played all the way through gun
survivor too like i've done that
um in one sitting as a kid
that was something that i was kind of
surprised by
did those two arrows just hit each other
in midair
maybe and blow up because you didn't get
hit by either of them um
you can definitely shoot arrows out of
out of the air which is cool
um
everything with doom eternal uh seat
yeah
it's wild that do maternal actually had
like
story to spoil that thing
it is uh but i i feel that for sure that
that there was a lot of fan service in
that one
uh core game looks good but side mode is
kind of lame
that's fair this isn't for for everyone
i think mercenaries
yeah i mean i think everyone's gonna be
hit or miss on whether they're into
mercenaries or not
yeah i i mean i'm gonna play it
obviously because
that's it's just what i do i'm kind
kind of sad that it's not like old
school mercenaries
but looks like a good time at least for
just a good kind of shooting around
deal but i'm sad it doesn't seem to have
multiple characters or seem to have
multiplayer because part of the fun of
mercenaries is
like getting a friend and going and
throwing zombies around together
uh do you think resident will go back to
doing co-op stuff like five and six
i don't know i was uh i was talking
about that with you
the other day about yeah how like
you you can almost like it feels like on
this
you know they rebooted the franchise in
some ways like mechanically with seven
and they're like all right we're gonna
go back to older resident evil and then
with this one it's like okay now we're
back to four and then it's like
does that mean they're gonna go back to
five and six like
is the cycle just gonna loop all over
another action game where they they put
in co-op stuff and then they go too far
and then you know we get to resident
evil 11 and they have to reboot it again
like
maybe that would be interesting i
would hope that uh capcom wouldn't
would kind of learn their lesson maybe
and not go too far this time but
i i've i am interested to see like where
they take it next
um yeah big same yeah well i think
that's about it
for showing everything off you know i
don't want to show off too much of um
uh mercenaries but i i think that was a
good taste of of that
and a good taste of the game so i i
think that might be where we call it uh
is there any other last
questions or people things people want
to know in the chat before we uh we
close this out
um not that i'm seeing right away but
we'll see if maybe some some stuff comes
out uh some questions about
uh how how excited we are for biomutant
versus resident evil 8 bio mutant versus
resident evil 8. i actually haven't paid
too much attention to biomutant
biomutant versus biohazard which one do
you want
uh well i i've already played
uh biohazard so i guess i guess i'll
check out biomutin next
um i don't really know if that game will
be for me but i'm kind of curious about
it because i've heard about it for like
a couple of years now
uh when does it come out when when does
russian village come out
it should supposedly come out uh
tonight at 9 00 p.m uh pacific standard
time
check your local your local time zones
uh to find out when
the game will be coming out for you uh
but yeah man
it's it's coming out you don't have long
to wait so uh
you know hopefully you guys enjoyed this
little
taste uh hopefully we were able to keep
it uh relatively spoiler free for you
all
so you're able to just kind of uh see
the game in action but not not really
get too spoiled
uh but thank you again for watching ben
thank you for joining me it's been a
really good time for having me yeah
dude uh it's exciting it's exciting to
be excited about resident evil we all we
all just love resident evil here so
uh yeah you know if you haven't already
checked it out uh and you're you want to
know more
go check out our review there's um the
video review as well as the written
piece over on gamespot.com buy the
excellent
philhorn shaw really knocked out the
park with that one uh we also have
some other stuff we have tips and tricks
that kurt did uh i don't think those are
up
yet i don't think they are either but
they will be up soon
um as well as my feature talking about
hardcore difficulty and why i think it's
a mode you should consider trying for
your first time playing through that
should hopefully be uploaded today
um also kurt did a really excellent
feature about
why we love to be chased in horror games
that just went up
um where he he interviewed uh some
people
like to talk about uh why he why
like we our brains love to be
chased if you've if you've seen our old
like uh remember when
type videos it's very much reminiscent
of that uh which is cool because i
uh i was like i said some people he
talked to a psychologist he talked like
a
yeah like a literal like a proper dude a
dude who knows what he's talking about
not just some
some guys who play video games uh but
anyway we got a lot of cool stuff around
resident evil so
go check that out if you're just you
know waiting to get excited about the
game
and uh yeah i hope you guys all have a
fantastic time uh with the game if you
get it uh now or if you know you decide
to wait later and
and pick it up um but anyway that's
gonna about do it for this stream
hope you all have a wonderful day and uh
we'll catch you next time
goodbye everybody
you